[Música]
E aí
é a ideia de uma luta com o popó não foi
nem uma ideia uma coisa que tem que
acontecer hoje chegando eu te dou um
[Música]
e vai chegar o trem chegar a menina aí
para treinar Bora pai agora quando você
vai montar o equipe Quando você vai
procurar as pessoas que você
responsáveis pelo seu sonho né porque
querendo não é uma ideia que você teve
você precisa Primeiro de tudo né as
pessoas erram e contratavam fazer o CD
de sertanejo meu primeiro Vou investir
500 mil e aí eu vou pegar o melhor tudo
bem ele é o melhor mas ele Talvez não tá
com você na mesma sintonia na mesma
ideia entendeu o Caio para mim é o
treinador que está comigo na minha ideia
vamos fazer uma luta
não acho que você já tá pronta hein mas
é que tempo agora é só a gente já foi
alguém tem hora que dá vontade né marido
de testar mas tinha que ser até que a
qualidade como eu sou formado em
educação física Eu podia entregar para o
índio em uma pessoa só toda a parte do
treinamento e como eu tenho a parte de
luta por trás foi mais fácil de fazer
acontecer a gente tem que fazer porque o
box e foi muito o Brasil também já foi
raspado o que que eu gosto quando eu
luto gosto eu gosto cara eu gosto de
força velocidade força pode então
trocação por isso eu gosto de boxe Nike
hard box do áudio também muito massa do
Cigano Mike Tyson Com certeza já foi ser
o mais vi ele de perto
eu nunca vi o nervil
e tem que respeitar ele sabe o caminho
né do construir um sucesso do que ele
fez e ele é só ele transferir o que ele
fez o do canal dele ele seu esse cara
que ele é ele transferir-se para o box
né então ele já sabe o caminho o que que
falta nele é residência eu tô fazendo o
que eu acho que vai acontecer na luta
dele o empurrar ali bastante volume
golpe em baixo ali na cintura que é um
golpe feminina bastante que você sente
muito tô tentando fazer bastante isso
mas bastante movimentação que o jogo do
Whindersson é um jogo de movimentar
pendulares que vá eu acho que vai dar
certo eu quero fazer muita resistência
na linha de cintura que eu sei que vai
tomar muito golpe baixo ali então ele
está desenvolvendo bem não cara
talentoso esquiva pendular movimento é
muito bem e agora está assimilando a
tomar muito suco forte é
e é tudo você pode estar melhor você é
melhor mas
se você não tiver força para continuar
Você tá igual na vida
eu
fui comprar se fortalecer é a filosofia
do esporte passa né
o parabéns com o cocô viu e você fez
campeão quatro vezes do Mundo desse aqui
é muita é muito sonho da educação também
está montando que pai
qual que é o plano quando sobe no ringue
a ganhar ganhar venha Para quê Para quê
Para poder chegar algum lugar para poder
chegar alguma parada isso aí Serviu de
alguma coisa para mim para aprender eu
já vou saber o que pode ser e
mentalizando a Vitória e se não ganhar
fez 0,1 porcento do meu processo
evolutivo mais feliz
o meu planos assim né ninguém sabe um
E aí
[Música]